[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants courent où frau
notre nounours est bien chargé ce soir
patron fois je bricole je descends aider
mes deux petits amis par réparer leurs
lumières
une simple formalité bon travail
nounours et sois prudent
merci patron bon le cheval portant à lui
vous aider je sais tout réparer oui on
va dit qu'il y avait eu l'an passé où se
trouve cette l'an passé par ici ne
logent dans la salle d'audience
alors fade plus près aux satellites
électrique
ce dernier vous pouvez jouer tranquille
en trois minutes
ce nom la poche on marque on tient ses
chronos y tu fais pas tenez shell
vous voulez rire les enfants musique
maestro en donnera du coeur à l'ouvragé
[Musique]
puis voilà
c'est réparé ne vous inquiétez pas la
langue ne paraît pas très droite mais
l'essentiel c'est qu'elle marche non
allah n'aime pas droites du taux n'ont
aucune importance
elle sanctionne il est temps au dodo
fermons le bonheur c'est un peu bizarre
il faudra que je revois ça à tête
reposée fermé la porte et à loudon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu sais je crois que c'est papa qui
valent à réparer la lumière pour lui la
gto n'ont pas toujours top annonces
[Musique]
venues grand bricoleur de nuit nicolas
fournit pas ponelle temps bien
[Musique]
à te voilà grand bricoleur me voilà au
tronc on y va mais oui en route
bonne nuit les enfants faites de beaux
rêves
à demain de boer
[Musique]